In 2011, the Great Tohoku Earthquake occurred.
When I saw the destruction of the city, my heart sank.
In spite of all of this,...
...I was drawn to the resilience and strength of the local people.
I left the big city for the nature of this village:...
...the ocean, the mountains, and rivers.
Inspired by the locals, we began a revitalization project...
...to restore an old traditional Japanese house in the village.
I also began farming indigo and creating sustainable good using aizome,...
...a traditional organic Japanese dyeing technique.
Being a mother and an entrepreneur is not easy,...
...but the women here support each other.
As a community, we are developing many projects together,...
...with the hope of revitalizing our city...
...and shaping a bright future for Minamisanriku.